were you in any musicals in high school
before you started modeling or acting I
know I did Oklahoma I remember Oklahoma
because when I was singing Siri with a
fringe on top I put my hand on the
microphone and the teacher like we were
on stage like we were performing and she
came out of the dark like I didn't see
her till the last second and she slapped
me in the side of my head like on stage
in front of my parents in front of all
these people and she goes she was never
touched the microphone and then she
turned and walked away cuz I think I got
a little rock star on it were you
embarass
no because I was like she's right I
don't know for some reason in I can
think of it now in the moment I was like
you're right I shouldn't have touched
the microphone I'm going to start
hitting you I got it I got the direction